welcome to Port Louis the capital of
Mauritius the island state on the
eastern coast of the African continent
is a melting pot of different cultures
and that's especially evident in the
cuisine chef red Ettin eke lies on the
outskirts of town but people come here
from all over the city
the French Asian and Creole fusion food
here is popular with customers that's
largely due to the skills of Chef Fred
Gunn Goro his specialty home made me
noodles melamine first you put in the
noodles and what are they made of laughs
I mean they're made of flour water and
other ingredients like salt remotely
through then comes white cabbage grated
carrots
the silicon and chives there are
countless me variations this one here is
with corn fed chicken then a bit of
shrimp sauce a dash of caramel syrup and
here's the French influence a generous
splash of white wine rapid mix
everything well and it's almost ready
another typical French ingredient is the
coarse sausage the surcease do finely
sliced it gives the dish its finishing
touch more sausage on good days
Fred cooks a hundred such portions
carefully meanwhile his wife uniike is
busy with the customers it's lunch time
and the restaurant is full and the
phone's ringing off the hook you can get
me to go if you bring your own plates in
addition to the noodle dishes Fred also
makes snacks like fried chicken or
Mauritian wonton lies within when the
customers see my husband's are they
either don't order noodles or they come
later
everything depends on him on him and the
perfect me noodles serve its egg on
white it's fast food many say we can't
keep eating your noodles or we'll get
fat I just say to them look around you
is anyone here overweight the main thing
is that people enjoy the food the noodle
dishes cost between 2 and 4 euros a
plate
the noodles with beef and egg are really
delicious
they serve the food quickly here too
sometimes I even come alone because it's
just so good the food at chef red atonic
is like mauritius itself a mix of
everything
Asian European and African